the raiders know this and so does kevin
martin she takes it away from the
henderson bowl
well thanks sean we have a huge rivalry
game going on behind me green valley is
hosting basic as you mentioned in the
henderson bowl and earlier tonight we
caught up with former raider james
harris who shared with us a memory from
his high school days and a rivalry game
i love my high school days since we
talked in high school a high school game
against east st louis lincoln
and i scored four touchdowns and i
shouldn't have scored any because i had
the flu and i went out there and played
my butt off and i played quarterback at
the time so you have a flu game everyone
talks about michael jordan's flu game
but james hayes has a flu game too i had
a flu game and i had a great time doing
it but afterwards i felt like crap
the gators have won the last three
straight henderson bowls including the
42 to nothing shutout win in 2019 and so
far looking like it might be three or
four straight excuse me it's still early
on but the gators are winning six
nothing of course we'll have highlights
of this one coming up at 11 reporting
live at green valley high school kevin
martin 8 sports now